now this is the shape this is [ __ ]
now I've got to point out a few really
important things to you okay firstly you
notice we've got this nice gentle curve
okay and it must be curved so firstly
get the shape right okay
secondly and this is actually quite hard
okay so pay attention you need to be
able to understand that from this graph
I can make a whole bunch of different
ones that are very similar it's like old
family if you're like okay and they come
by two ways right there's a shift up and
down right so we call that and then you
can shift it left and right which is
horizontal and in fact you can do both
at the same time I'll show you how okay
so here's y equals x squared right now
if I compare that to say y equals x
squared plus one it's the exact same
shape but everything's being moved up
with that's all okay so I'll try my best
and I want to draw exactly the same
shape but just to sum like this I guess
roughly it starts to deteriorate over
there that's the idea so it's been moved
up with I can move it down with as well
so how would I do that instead of going
x squared plus one how would I move down
with so much okay
exactly the same shape but move down
with okay so some like this
okay like so so you got a whole family
dude then this is a this is a vertical
shift I'm just moving it up and down
okay so how would you move it left and
right this is kind of a tricky ah very
good no can I just say it again because
that's a huge idea I don't know where
nah I didn't know where there is blind
luck or it was just like I've been
sitting on this idea like half an hour
Lucas is exactly right
and there's a really clever reason why
it's not just random okay um these
numbers that we're adding or subtracting
right even though they're over here on
the right hand side actually what
they're really changing is the Y value
I'll show you this equation what would
it look like if I took the one over the
other side it would be y1
it'll be Y wait I've got to subtract one
from both sides can you see that these
two are the same I've subtracted I've
taken is equated and I've subtracted 1
from both sides so it's equivalent in
exactly the same way I can add 1 to both
these sides and I'm gonna give this okay
now it makes sense that when you put
numbers like you add numbers or you take
my numbers from Y you go up and down how
come what did what is y about which
one's the y-axis it's the up-down axis
right so it makes sense when you muck
around with the y value you should go up
and down okay so what happens if we muck
around with the x value like Lukas is
suggesting so here's how I'm gonna do it
I'll draw my original x squared in there
like that okay so this y equals x
squared now how do I change the X well
I'll add or subtract something from it
like this I'll do this okay so you can
see this it's still all squared but I'm
taking one away from it before I squared
okay you can go ahead you can draw the
table of values you can try the ball
that and get coins but I'll save you a
bit of time okay this thing is going to
be the same as this shape but it's gonna
be moved to the right it's gonna look
like this yeah that's right that's
exactly right sorry so I should move
these over there bit suspect so my
original one was y equals x square yeah
and then this blue one I've just drawn
is y equals x minus 1 squared okay for
instance I can show you the most
important point here the turning point
the vertex right it's there right you
put in x equals 1 you get 1 minus 1
squared equals 0 there you go you think
- should go that way right there's a
very very good intuition to have but it
doesn't work I'll show you let's
actually do the young we have just
enough time to do a quick table of days
I've just seen I've just seen these
thousands of times before
would you want draw up a table of values
for this one for me we'll do this one
together so pick up your pen now
I need okay we're going to try the same
values we had before negative 2 negative
1 0 1 2 so what happens when you put in
for instance x equals 0 what's gonna
happen
I'm putting x equals 0 and here so
you're gonna get 0 minus 1 1 0 minus 1
minus 1 square what's minus 1 square
that's one one more like one like that
ok let's let's keep going this way what
happens when I put in 1 I'll have 1
minus 1 which is 0 and then I square it
which is 0 ok what happens when I put 2
in and be 2 minus 1 which is 1 and then
I squared which is 1 can now be the
other way what happens on a pretty minus
1 n minus 1 minus 1 minus 2 and then I
square it which gives me you're
recognizing these numbers from before
aren't you minus 2 minus 2 minus 1 gives
you minus 3 and then you square it which
gives you 9 so now when you test out
these values can you see look this shape
hasn't been moved to the left it's been
moved this way but not as we got before
with these can you see they've all gone
this way look C to the right
and so if I were to go the other way
okay if I had not X minus one squared
but X plus one good okay that's gonna go
the other way like so okay let's go on
to the left
yep what if you take the square root
there's not a great question y equals
sir I'm just gonna put some labels on
this before I answer your question
that's one one and that it also be a